these guys these properties are these
you can quote okay they could have your
results so they really really important
they've got to be kind of like part of
the fabric of your mind because when you
are going to be given inequality these
are kind of your background right laughs
how do we use them okay so here
different something if you could give it
an equality question or year in an
induction question and an inequality
appears you have to somehow work with it
you've got three choices so number one
is just start with all these properties
you know how in binomial theorem we're
just looking at UM by new identities
right and I said to you frequently the
first slide you write down is just some
version of the binomial theorem right
you write down ah this guy is just the
sum from 0 to n of what
and see ah oh you can say they're coming
to bless I'd probably say exit the ark
alright so and I knew it was going on
okay so this might be your starting line
and then you say okay for a particular
value of x or what happens if I square
the whole field or whatever okay in
exactly the same way any one of these
things I take this guy or this guy or
this guy they might be the first line
you write and then you guys from there
should try and work towards whatever is
all they were to prove so there's number
one okay number two you can prove by
contradiction so we haven't looked at
this very much I'm gonna give you an
example this morning proof by
contradiction is you get given a result
you just assume it's wrong assume the
opposite is the case and then if you
work with that and apply logic you
should come up with something which is
clearly false according to these puppies
that you know right maybe you get to
some point in your like are I factorize
after starting with this wrong
assumption I have a square but
apparently according to the inequality I
have started with that square should be
negative but that contradicts unknown
property right so you can start from
something that it's wrong and it's sure
that it's wrong lastly and this is kind
of a tricky solid to a simple example
with you if what you get is a non
algebraic function somehow hiding in
your
inequality okay so everything you're
looking at the board it's algebra
you've got peripherals you combine it
with addition subtraction multiplication
division exponentiation okay
all of that is algebra what's not
algebra a trig functions Exponential's
other like as in if you've got e to the
X rather X to the whatever okay
logs are not algebraic all these kinds
of things if you meet one of them are
your inequality you're basically have to
use calculus okay you have to use
calculus now I will all show you exactly
how it's going to work but to give you a
bit of a tease right calculus has two
parts to it two sides of the same coin
what's the first part differentiation so
for instance they bite what should prove
okay I've got some kind of function I
want to show it's always bigger than
whatever okay well you might be able to
differentiate show that it's an
increasing function right it's a oh look
I start from here and I always go up
there for I'm always going to be greater
than whatever value I started out right
so if you know what the function is you
can differentiate your gradient function
and so on what's the other part
integration so think for a moment
what kind of problem is integration
designed to solve it's designed to solve
an area problem so if what you get you
might like to draw a little diagram like
this if what you get is like a a
function of some kind
okay since integration is going to tell
you area what are the easy ways to get
an inequality out of something like this
is to simply saying hey you know before
we knew what integration was we had to
approximate areas by say oh this area
underneath the curve right this guy
underneath here is what I want I know
that this area under the curve it has to
be less than this trapezium up here see
that I'm gonna call this corner few
because it's a chord along my curve
right it's going to be less than that so
can you see right there just off that
that's an inequality right you can get
an expression for the big trapezium then
you can integrate to find the area under
the curve and say this is bigger than
this I in just the same way I could do
it in Reverse suppose I've got the
inequality face in the other direction
there's a trapezium that is easy to
define its underneath if I just take the
tangent at a particular point in that
interval right can you see I've got now
here underneath the tanjur depending on
the concavity of my curve right
underneath the tangent I've got a new
trapezium and that trapezium has to be
less than the area of the integral does
that make sense so again another
inequality for you so if you see some
more curve or side or whatever like that
then you know calculus is gonna be
involved because you can't just mucking
around with it just like this